When you think of cutting edge technology
at sea, you might be
thinking of stuff like this.
But there's an incoming
revolution on the high seas
that isn't quite as sexy,
but could be significantly more impactful.
Container shipping is the key
component of global trade.
About 80 or 90% of all the
world's goods are transported
at sea at some point.
And these ships carry trillions
of dollars of goods on them
and without them, there
would be no globalization.
But there's a significant unseen cost
to the modern era of global commerce.
About 3% of all the
world's CO2 emissions come
from shipping.
3% may not sound like a lot,
but that's roughly comparable
to the entire CO2 output
of Germany, or in other
words around the same amount
of emissions from all
forms of aviation combined.
Since reducing trade
isn't a likely option,
what about a technological
improvement to help reduce
the emissions from these
well-stocked maritime behemoths?
Transport by the sea
has always been the most
cost-efficient method of moving.
It was like that in the Stone Age
and it's still like that today.
In the more recent history
it was in the 1970s
that the big breakthrough
came when the use
of the standard-sized
containers became the norm.
That's really what revolutionized trade
and made globalization as
we know it today possible.
Today, we are used to
buying things in Europe
and the U.S that's made in China.
50 years ago, that was not the norm.
That's the containers
that made that possible.
Only about six or 7,000
container ships handle
this big conveyor belt of goods.
They have doubled in size many times over
during the last couple of decades
and now the biggest container
ships there are can carry
more than 20,000 containers
and they're longer than 400 meters.
So why not electrify
a fleet of cargo ships
and take advantage of the
emissions cuts that come with it?
Well, some are trying.
Take Yara, a fertilizer company in Norway,
and their electric autonomous
ship, The Birkeland.
And we can start by
addressing the question,
why is a fertilizer company
building ships at all?
We have a lot of focus of
making sustainable products,
producing food for the whole population
in the sustainable way
is one of important tasks
that we as a company see.
And transportation and the
supply chain is also part
of the environmental load
that we put on the society.
The Birkeland, it's unique
because it is electric
and then also emission-free and
it's going to be autonomous,
without any ship crew on board.
We are exporting about
20,000 containers a year,
so that will then eliminate
40,000 truck drives
through the town of Porsgrunn.
The Birkeland isn't
going to be any cheaper
to operate than a traditional
vessel, at least for now.
But according to Yara,
that's not its purpose.
It is more the effect on the environment,
reducing CO2 emission and
also an important factor
that this ship has got a lot of attention
and it's been the kind of a
catalyst for the others also
to develop green maritime transport.
But the Yara Birkeland has
a significant limitation, range.
A similarly-sized vessel with
a diesel engine can travel
up to 5,000 nautical miles,
the Yara Birkeland, around 80.
They will use it for a very
specific route in Norway
between two sites fairly
close to each other.
The ship can carry about 120 containers
and you would need about 200
of these small ships to match
one of the very large container vessels
that's out out there.
So the Yara Birkeland has a solid,
but niche potential application.
For longer range ships, the
technology faces the same issues
that were common to early road-going EVs.
If you look at a Tesla,
Tesla has a battery that
weighs 1,200 pounds.
If you should fit a battery
into a container ship
that's 400 meters long,
it would just be massive.
Because of these limitations,
the industry's heavy hitters
are turning elsewhere
for carbon cutting.
Maersk, the world's
largest shipping company
by vessels owned, currently
consumes around 12 million tons
of oil per year, which is
about what the entire
world produces every day.
In order to reach its goal of
being carbon neutral by 2040,
the company is looking to
change up what's in the tank.
The power requirements are just too high
for battery technology at the moment.
You're talking about
ships with an engine on
with more than a hundred
thousand horse power.
In the marine industry,
the only real way to reduce
emissions is to actually change the fuel.
To begin that change, Maersk turned to
MAN Solutions.
MAN Energy Solutions is
part of the Volkswagen group
and the oldest industrial
company in Germany founded
in 1758.
We're a little bit different
to the car industry
because we operate in the marine industry.
With A.P. Moller-Maersk,
we'll receive an order
for 12 methanol fuel ships.
So the idea is to have
a carbon neutral ship,
completely carbon neutral.
Methanol's quite an interesting fuel
because, of course, it's very CO2 neutral.
The second thing is it's
liquified at ambient temperature,
so actually it's relatively
simple to store and use.
the genius thing about the
engines that we produce is
because of our modular
design, we can actually modify
the engines fairly simply
to run on different fuels.
And actually, a lot of
our engines are supplied
in a dual fuel mode,
so they can run on one fuel today
and a different fuel tomorrow.
There's many types of new
fuels that will allow us
to decarbonize the industry.
But of course, what we need
is a kind of transition
and you can go to liquid natural gas
or even synthetic natural
gas, which give us
good reductions in CO2.
We intend to have a vessel
operating in 2024 on ammonia,
which, of course, is the
absolute game changer
in terms of emissions.
Some of these alternative fuels,
however, have drawbacks.
We're looking at ammonia,
which is a highly toxic chemical,
but a it's also CO2 neutral.
Obviously the disadvantage
is that it's very dangerous
both for humans and marine life.
Liquified natural gas, some
shipping lines are looking
at that.
The problem with that
is obviously that it's
not CO2 neutral, it just
reduces the CO2 emissions
from the ships.
But another solution is methanol,
which is sourced from green electricity.
Methanol is readily available today
and really is carbon neutral.
Of all the technologies, I
think methanol is for sure
the short or medium-term future.
There's an infrastructure around methanol.
I think methanol, at the moment,
seems to be more available
and, of course, the technology's proven.
Although switching
to alternative fuels is
expected to add 10 to 12%
to shipping costs, this
could be the perfect time
for shipping companies to add
in a buffer for that premium.
In the last two years,
the industry has been
in great shape.
And the reason why
they're in great shape is
while many are aware of
that the world suffers
from supply chain issues, but
it's actually an advantage
for the companies that own the ships
because they can charge
higher prices at the moment.
So there's a lot of cash flow
in the container shipping
industry right now
and that should enable the companies
and the ship owners to
invest in new technologies
that reduce global emissions.
While these mammoth vessels make
incremental progress in decarbonizing,
smaller ships are more readily
adopting new technologies.
Take Promare's Mayflower vessel.
Using hybrid solar, wind,
and diesel propulsion,
it's equipped to travel
autonomously with no crew to conduct
research on marine health.
It's designed to cruise around the oceans
and collect scientific data.
So climate data, water quality data,
data about marine mammals,
and bring back samples
and also transmit samples off the boat
into the ether for consumption
by the scientific community.
According to Promare, the advantages
of the Mayflower being
unmanned and AI driven will be
both in its increased efficiency
and its ability to go
where most ships never do.
One of the things to bear in mind
with these vessels is once you
remove all the people stuff,
they become extremely efficient
in the sense that the power
it takes to move this vessel
over long distances is
absurdly low by comparison
to a vessel the same size
carrying people on it.
It's very, very green because
it just sips on the fuel,
but it's a dual electric
motors that are driven
by lithium iron phosphate battery systems,
similar to what you'd find in the Tesla.
And then there are
solar panels that charge
emergency batteries and then
also charge the main batteries
so that if we lose main
propulsion for some reason,
the solar power and battery
systems that are adjacent
to the primary batteries will
keep the navigation, lights,
and communications and position data live.
Then the main batteries that
drive the engines and run
all the sophisticated systems
are periodically charged
by a biodiesel generator.
So we can use biofuel or
we can use straight diesel,
whichever we prefer.
It doesn't replace
ships with people on it,
but it sort of democratized
the ability to collect data
and produce information
that we can all share
so that when we do send
a very expensive ship
with people on it out
for very long voyages
into the middle of nowhere,
that those people are
best spending their time
on the areas that will
produce the most results
in terms of answering the big questions
that boats like this help to ask.
The dream would be to have many,
many, many ships like this.
So if you look at where we
get our data about the ocean,
it's almost completely biased
to the commercial shipping channels,
ships going back and forth
on major trading routes.
Ships like Mayflower
and many others like it,
both very small ones, even
larger ones are what we need
to kind of reduce the cost of collecting
that fundamental data and producing
that sort of first tier of information.
Promare plans to send the Mayflower
on its first trans-Atlantic
voyage in April.
Across the pond in Alameda, California,
another company is
looking to commit swarms
of electric autonomous drones to the seas.
That company is Saildrone.
The first vehicles were designed to be
data-gathering robots that
really gather atmospheric
and oceanographic data, which
is kinda the critical piece
of the puzzle we need to
understand climate change
and the rate of change.
So we started gathering
data on fish stocks,
on water column itself.
That led us to ocean mapping,
so mapping the sea bed.
What we excel at with the
robot is kind of the long,
monotonous, or dangerous things
that people shouldn't be doing.
So persistent present
operations in the high Arctic,
Southern Ocean, where
it's just too rough to go
with a human.
Hurricane exploration is a great example.
The boats are electric
vehicles so they run
on battery power.
It is wind-powered
propulsion and solar-powered
for the electricity for
the computers and so on.
Electrification of marine systems is key,
but I'll go further than that saying
it's not just electrification,
it's harnessing renewable sources
of wind and solar to power
those vehicles along.
The real challenge for any
maritime vessel is having
enough power on board to propel you.
So if you don't harvest
power along the way,
you have to carry that as stored power,
either a huge amount of batteries
or an alternative fuel source,
diesel, hydrogen, or other.
So for us, we try and maximize each fuel
to renewable sources and
obviously that's wind,
sailing ships, kind of one
of the oldest technologies
on the planet and a true, reliable,
and sustainable form of power.
So we utilize that a lot
and that reduces the amount
of fuel you have to take
and it reduces the
amount of mechanical load
on the vehicles.
Less time you can run an engine for,
the longer that's gonna last.
But there are areas of the
world where you don't have
a lot of sunlight.
Northern hemisphere in the
winter and up in the Arctic.
Obviously, a little bit's frozen,
but in the unfrozen area
where where we operate,
you have very very low light levels.
Very short days, very short summers.
And that means we struggle for
power in the winter months.
Right now we're using
high-efficiency small diesel engines
that run at kind of a very
efficient RPM to charge batteries
in a very short period of time.
So like a diesel-electric system on a ship
where you use engines to charge batteries
and then you run the ship off batteries.
Having backup combustion engines proves
just how hard it will be
for ocean-going vessels
to completely ditch carbon-emitting fuels.
Regardless, stakeholders in
the industry seem to agree
that progress must continue and fast.
If we can decarbonize this industry
and we need to act very, very quickly
because it's not just about the new ships,
it's about the existing ships,
then we can have a dramatic
impact to make sure
we hit the targets that been set out.
We needed to act yesterday, not tomorrow,
we needed to act yesterday.
So the quicker we can get this moving,
then the better for everybody.